guys lovin part 2 of our epic comic-con
coverage if you miss part 1 it featured
a lot of boobs yeah
some crazy cosplay hijinks click here if
you want to see it or just sit back and
wait cuz we got some cool stuff right
now you can watch it after this episode
so guys there's a lot of big news at
Comic Con there was Batman Superman news
there was x-men news but something that
got me really excited was the Avengers 2
news
Joss Whedon took the stage and revealed
the title Avengers 2 the age of Ultron I
brought in a couple of our good friends
school me give us a little info about
Ultron first he is the head mad monster
at mad monster calm Evan magar glad to
be here he's the writer of torso and
Manhunter mr. mark and Rico good to see
you huh let's say you're talking to a
baby
what is ultron a crucial part of
Ultron's genesis is Hank Pym most people
know him as ant-man yeah Hank Pym was a
scientist who invented first a shrinking
gas that made him be able to shrink
sizes he was ant-man first and he became
giant man his wife was the wasp and they
were actually two of the original
Avengers Ultron is artificial
intelligence Hank Pym created a robot
with his brain patterns and it became
sentient as it gradually evolved it
became a very high-powered villain how
awesome is Ultron how much asking it
kick wealth roads a great villain he's
made of adamantium the same material the
Wolverines metal is made of and
internally he's a nuclear reaction it's
potentially a pretty terrifying villain
which surprises me that they're going
that way with Disney being the producer
of this because you know the Marvel
Studios movies so far I've had a little
bit of edge but Ultron could be
absolutely so Ron is like he's of
syndrome's robot and the Borg and it is
a classic science fiction trope of
artificial intelligence going wrong from
Forbidden Planet to terminator yeah mm
wonder what's computers and how yes what
do we thinks gonna happen in Avengers 2
yeah I'm pretty sure you know it's gonna
be a an example of them inadvertently
creating a monster and then having to
deal with not just with the
repercussions of what the monster does
but the guilt and the public perception
of what they've been least on the city
it's like having another
haven't you mentioned this is kind of a
bittersweet announcement Oh what's up
well see Ultron is integral to the Hank
Pym character which is why it's just
such such better material for ant-man
film makes sense except that they're
omitting them from Avengers 2 I'm hoping
this is misdirect or just some kind of
shenanigans in the park production but
if if they remove Hank Pym from Ultron's
origin this is gonna be a huge letdown
they're just taking the name age of
Ultron but it's not the same story you
know you could keep it as a mystery you
can keep a standalone ant-man film by
having them introduce Ultron try to
figure out who the hell this guy is and
you find it's based on this guy's brain
brain patterns and then a separate film
who is this guy
here's a quote from Whedon we're doing
our own Ultron origin story Hank Pym is
not in the movie and he finishes by
saying tough so there's some there's
some mixed thoughts here but at the end
of the day I'm pretty excited
what about DC what do we think about
this Batman Superman news it's like
building a mansion on marshland you know
if you're gonna build off that Man of
Steel film no interest no interest yeah
it does seem like they're skipping a
step I completely disagree oh yeah I'm a
big proponent of Man of Steel I think I
think Man of Steel was a great way to
reboot the franchise yes a flawed movie
but every movie have it has its flaws
this one the stuff that worked for me a
Man of Steel worked so well that I was
willing to overlook some of the other
stuff I will say I'm a little nervous
they're not doing a Superman - before
they do Superman Batman because the
stuff that people know is Clark Kent of
The Daily Planet in Metropolis and you
have a great opportunity to get a little
bit lighter because the biggest
complaint with Man of Steel is it's a
big tower it's a bit dark so I want to
see close
so let's lighten it up with the Dark
Knight yeah DC seems are you rushing
this Marvel has them chasing their tail
that's what it is I mean I would have
preferred George Miller's aborted
attempt where they were just going to do
a Justice League film trust that your
audience has grown up on the
Superfriends and every incarnation of
Justice League we really don't need
another origin thing if you just said
here's a dude who hangs out with fish
here's an alien you know you know a cape
and here's Batman we know these
characters best thing they could do is
just get Nolan the hell away from this I
mean he thinks you know he has to you
know apologize for the source material I
don't agree at all I think I think that
the product
Rises that was terrible I disagree I
disagree
you like bein interested in this guy you
can't understand sweet kind of the
Swedish Chef from the Muppets we sounded
like to me yeah I love bein do you like
Bane Bane is badass you have my
permission to stop talking negative
thing about brains
we agree that they're rushing a little
bit into Batman vs Superman
who do we trust more Joss Whedon or Zack
Snyder I vote nothing above I mean they
they both have they both look I'm
impressed with you even failed us like
the comic store guy from The Simpsons
even if it's coming a little too quick
I'm super excited for Batman for
Superman what movie are you more excited
for Avengers 2 the age of Ultron or
Batman for Superman leave an answer in
the comments section below tell us why
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt and don't forget to watch part 1
of our comic-con coverage that features
just ridiculous crap from Comic Con so
much cool stuff
I want to thank cinnamon out from Best
Buy and I also want to thank our awesome
guests for talking comics with us
Evan magar and Mark and Draco thank you
for watching screen junkies on how our
odd Nick bye-bye
[Music]